34 عاما مضت على اعلى في حادث ارهابي شهدت
الاراضي البريطانيه تفجير لاكر به الذي
راح ضحيته 270 شخصه لتبدا معها محطات
القضيه الابرص انطلاقا من عام 2003 حينما
اقرت ليبيا بمسؤوليتها عن حادث تفجير
اللكربي في اسكتلندا
2020 حين وجهت امريكا تهاما بالضلوع في
التخطيط وتصنيع قنبله
بالارهاب لمواطن ليبي يدعى ابو عجيل مسعود
المغربي
امنعم الجاري فشاهده نوفمبر الماضي احداث
متسارعه اعاده قضيه اللقبي للواجهه بعد
الجدل الذي اثاره اختفاء ابو عجيل مسعود
في ظروف غامضه تقارير اعلاميه قالت انه
خططف من داخل السجن بالعاصمه طرابلس بينما
ظهر بيان وعائلته انه اختطف من منزله
ليطالب بعدها المجلس الاعلى للدوله حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه
بدوره كان رد حكومه الدبيبه مقتضب عبر
بيان اصدرته وزاره العدل تطرقت فيه لرفضها
فتح ملف قضيه
معلمه انه اغلق بالكامل سياسيا وقانونيه
لكن دون ان تتطرق للتهم الموجهه لها او
ملابسات اختفاء ابو عجيله
اما روايه ابو عجيله فكانت مناقضه لتلك
الرسميه عائلته قالت في بيان انه في
السادس عشر من نوفمبر الماضي اقتحم مسلحون
بملابس مدنيه منزلهم في العاصمه طرابلس
واختطفوا ابو عجيله وقت دوه لجهه غير
معلومه عزه اسرته وحيده اختطافها لاغراض
سياسيه ترمي الى الاضرار بالمصالح العليا
للبلاد
اخر محطات لغز اختفاء ابو عجينه كان في
ديسمبر الجاري بعد اعلان الولايات المتحده
ان المتهم المطلوب لديها ابو عجيله بترانا
الاحتجاز لديها دون ان توضح كيف وقع متهم
لكربي بقبضه
[موسيقى]